valérie benaïm c'est votre conseil de
classe aujourd'hui c'est votre que
c'était votre combientième saison 10e
dixième à vache dixième saison valérie
bénaïm pour acer est dixième saison
daniel j'espère qu'en france
c'est vrai tu t'accroches race en hausse
et se sont tus nous enterrera tous
vous allez donc jugé valérie bénaïm ont
fait des marines par bernard montiel
aller - valérie faut que je dis je
t'aime beaucoup parce qu'on a trois
points communs on a commencé à tf1 on
n'aime pas dire du mal des gens enfin en
public et on murmure tous les deux à
l'oreille des puissants moi je discute
avec nemo le chien de l'elysée et toi
avec ton chien me dit voilà ça c'est
vrai et alors cette année c'est toi qui
a écrit ça
coince à l'époque c'est toi ton côté tu
es chez toi tu écris as
[Rires]
rome était le contrat dans un corps sain
mais cette année cette année mal et rita
pas eu peur d'y aller et a pris du poil
de la bête tu étais contre les méchants
tu étais pour les gentils tout ça on a
été assez ému et puis alors tu vois je
voulais mettre une bonne note mais il se
trouve que comme tu m'as piqué quelques
six à sept mois faut quand même le dire
et peut
5,5 alors
bien fait
les shérifs nous rejoignent et de 19h05
on est en direct c'est le conseil de
classe de valérie si vous avez compris
ce qu a dit bernard montiel
est pas si l'année au plus vite à les
oiseaux s'affiche sur bada s'il vous
plaît dites le nous
incarnons ici sur le plateau nous
n'avons rien compris nous n'avons rien
capté on ne sait pas ce que ce garçon
dit
que je voulais rajouter qui était
important la seule fois où elle a ouvert
sa bouche de façon intéressante c'est
quand elle a roulé une pelle à des films
explique membres à bon ben voila tu vois
tu veux tu es mieux quand tu écris
allez on va passer à daniel mots alors
valérie tuer la voix de la raison tu es
notre maman a tous je
suis la bonne copine quand m6
mais justement tu a les défauts de ses
qualités parfois un peu trop bonne
copine fait cette brouille un petit peu
le jugement et tuer même à la limite de
la [ __ ] donc dans les seules du sus
âge qui va de un à dix c'est à dire de
bernard montiel à guillaume genton puis
jetée classe à peu près à cette issue
sauteuse on va dire donc mon conseil
pour analyser la chaîne sus - est mort
plus on ajouté
et là c'est pas mal
ce soit est mort conseil c'est peut-être
ça n'avait pas de mec
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
savez azizi n'est pas en épis de maïs
c'est vrai
si vous même c'est vrai allez on va à
des notes cette branche est né avec
béatrice alors moi je voulais un joker
parce que comme je viens d'arriver je
pensais ne pas pouvoir me permettre de
te noté évidemment mais dans cette
émission il n'y a pas de joker n'y a pas
de joker alors donc va hériter c'est
qu'on se connaît pas très bien mais on
se connaît suffisamment pour être
d'accord sur le fait qu'on ait jamais
d'accord quand je dis blanc tu dis moi
quand je dis oui tu dis non bref comme
je pense avoir toujours raison et que c
est souvent j'ai quand même décidé de
couper la poire en deux et
et de te mettre 5 parce que la vérité
sûrement quelque part entre nous deux à
mi chemin entre nous voilà
c'est pas mal c'est bien ça soude ses
conseils des
récits très bien
c'est bien on va enchaîner
19h09 heure huit mois ça va être court
si
vite je pense qu'il est réveillé je vais
tenter
vous garantit rien chez vous je vais
tenter voilà je vais tenter d'abord de
l'appeler pour voir voilà près de cent
fois réveillée vraiment je vous garantis
rien parce que je sais pas s'il est là
je fais voir donc je l'appelle là et on
va voir parce que vraiment je pense
qu'il est je pense qu'il dort encore à
19h08 je pense qu'on pense qu'il va
falloir à l'appeler je pense qu'il va
falloir appeler vers 20h15 alors
je te réveilles 0
[Rires]
parce que même au téléphone qu'on pourra
allez encore une petite de 5 heures
tapantes nous avons dans le dos quand
même oh bah vous savez il ya beaucoup
ont dit ça et après que sont repartis
très contents
allez kelly mais nos vignes du mari
c'est juste pour le réveiller pour le
mettre en éveil parce que ça peut tomber
à tout moment
alors val moi j'ai toujours pensé que
c'était asexuée bon donc c'est ma
cinquième année je me suis toujours dit
mais ça arrive c'est pas un défaut t16
fuite et n'a pas de ressentiment au
niveau de ta petite culotte et
qui équipe son avis et c'est chacun le
vit comme il le sent après si tu le vis
mal c'est autre chose je vais en parler
on
peut en discuter je connais un peu le
sujet voilà je fais toi magics non pas
du tout mais je connais plein de gens
qui en parlent si tu veux je peux te
faire entrer dans un groupe au delà de
ça ce que j'ai beaucoup aimé cette année
c'est que tu as montré ton côté animal
nous on avait l'animal le chef et on a
le côté animal valérie bénaïm autant au
niveau professionnel autant au niveau
sexuel que au niveau de la chroniqueuse
c'est tout moi j'ai trouvé ma tête quand
je t'ai vu la semaine dernière je me
suis dit ça y est il est là son côté
sexuel qui rament à plus de voir ses
courbes avez vous vu dans la piscine
là je vois ce qui se passe quelque chose
dans ta tête danton slop
suis dit ah mais non en fait elle cacher
c'est peut-être par pudeur peut-être par
respect pour les autres donc j'ai
beaucoup aimé ce côté animal en toi
peut-être si le fait d'avoir côtoyé
cyril vous donnez nous toutes ces années
là au-delà de ça au niveau de la
chroniqueuse je trouve que cette année
qui a été fort qui a été fort c'était
beaucoup retomber dessus satee sata
beaucoup aussi affaiblie mais tu es
revenue plus forte après grâce au chef
aussi qui tapotaient aussi re motiver
voilà c'est le temps de s'éloigner des
revenus tu as été forte et pour ça moi
je te mets un 8 sur 10 pour tous
c'est bon
c'est bon on va enchaîner
avec guillaume raymond tu tues tu
reprends mes esprits
et là que je veux voir et vous soit des
billets dans ces endroits
de la moule annoncé suite à deux lames
ou là dans tes yeux droit dans sa
potence pour est un son gilles savary
très bien je voudrais oublier
ça vous arrive c'est toi va bien ça va
super c'était le week-end très bien ça
fait quoi j'ai attendu fatto qu'était
allez vas-y geek belle et riche tu
aimais beaucoup alors qu'il était dans
le top 15 de mes chroniqueurs préférés
je ne cache pas que tu viens de sortir
du top merde ce que tu as fait récemment
avec siri dans le contredisant sur les
anglais et sur les anglais une faute
grave qui doit être sanctionné tu as
fait d'accord comment oses-tu contredire
cyril alias m ba ba ce génie qui chaque
jour oeuvre pour un monde meilleur
j'ai grave le sommes néanmoins je trouve
que tu es quelqu'un de très fines goode
qui divertit toute la famille devant
s'est vite je t'aime bien 4
on va enchaîner maintenant avec raymond
tabac toi ouais ça va ça va pas trop
d'émotions non c'est bien c'est bien et
sur la centrale des particuliers
dans la vallée rémois t'as vu j'ai rien
écrit valérie pour moi tu es là tu es la
grande soeur s'est fait partie des
personnes que je préfère le plus dans
l'émission puisque avant l'émission tu
tu nous met en condition tu rigole
toujours jeter en face de moi toute
l'année juste en face de moi je vois
dans ton regard des fois quand ça va
quand ça va pas quand je dis des trucs
bien on se suit néanmoins je trouve que
cette année tu as comme a dit kelly show
je rejoins kelly je trouve que cette
année avec les propos que tu as dit que
ça a pris beaucoup de risques parce que
tu prend beaucoup de risques et souvent
en contre contre l'avis de cyril et tout
mais j'ai trouvé que sa dette était un
ton en dessous un ton en dessous que tu
prenais pas les grilles ce que tu
prenais d'habitude mais on est tout est
toujours là on se repose toujours toi
sur les débats on se repose sur toi tu
es meilleur quand il était moins payée
là
on
[Applaudissements]
peut faire confiance dans les débats tu
es là tu rajoute jean lé bas je te mets
moi valérie ma copine un grand 7
19h13 je vais rappeler moi
c'est bon t'es jamais ça va mais
surperforme havane en direct par
bakchich en pleine forme qu'est ce qui
va pas bah rien ne va en fait alors il
va pas des fois
on va voir déjà si tu arrives à aligner
trois mots dont danny ferry ont été
attaqués bon ben ali bagheri comme on le
sait tu es la plus gentille du plateau
la plus gentille c'est vrai la plus
gentille du plateau mais gentille c'est
pas un métier et pire encore dans tpm
paix gentil c'est un défaut tu vas dire
du mal mais pas trop du bien avec un
bémol bref c'était un pays tu serais la
suisse mais comme le dit très justement
cyril suisse n est pas trompé
[Rires]
en
temps de paix comme j'ai dit celui-ci
n'est pas tombé moi j'ai tu racontes en
tête mais c'est moi tu sais ce que tu
sais je
comprends ça sorte de tabou
c'est pas possible autrement on connaît
ce qui passe d'abord on dirait que ça
fait sa tête ses faux seins et
directement la
vie le attention et
0 chez nous ça fait pas attention toile
à
7,27 mal de
serre la main
celle d'un mec tu as la triche est là
bref c'est tout c'est mon ami peeta
alors ouais les deux on est comme un
frère et une soeur on est un tout ça et
en plus un ça fait
ebru tu te laisses comme ça arrive manif
fait quoi mais c'est pourquoi pas
les oreilles à
si toi je vais je vais te taper vous
allez 12 ans rien
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
de toi
là
bas dit vas-y vas-y
bettencourt comme ça pour aller à ma
place
si je veux aller de la voilà je vois pas
je vois pas non pas sinon à bazian
boutin l'étonnement fontaine de quoi que
attends j'ai passé mon retour en corse
est donc alors valérie s'était pas
produit une pression non
à 7 ans bras de fer
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
allez on va finir avec gilles verdez
faire d'aller en note
gilles verdez qui fait une année
magnifique voulais dire dans l'émission
mais
tu fais une année magnifique gilles bâti
jean valéry très franchement c'est la
saison que j'attendais
enfin vous vous êtes lâchés au quai des
phrases chocs un argumentaire puissant
ça a commencé au mois d'octobre avec
cette phrase l'amour c'est beau
[Applaudissements]
le sel c'est ça les
fumées tuent péter
et puis bien entendu cette phrase dont
tout le monde se souvient surtout vous
cyril c'était le 8 octobre ils étaient
19h48 et là on risque je cite un haut
risque de me mettre tout le monde à dos
je la firme cyril et bien coiffée
court j'avais été extraordinaire vous ai
dit 'je suis un peu injuste parce qu'il
ya des moments où vous êtes vraiment
lâchés et des moments on a retrouvé on a
trouvé même une valérie hargneuse cd
qu'on a touché à géraldine alors là dès
qu'on touche à votre amie géraldine
c'est fini alors là c'est valérie
géraldine tu as raison géraldine oui
c'est ça il faut se faire vacciner est
extraordinaire c'est extraordinaire vous
alors il faut noter ce binôme de la
bien-pensance comment noter un binôme et
bien binôme c'est un duo donc j'ai dû
diviser la gauche
dure
est-ce que vous passez d'un très
honorable 0,5
[Applaudissements]
l'adolescent s'est lui classé meilleur
reste il est drôle ils étaient alors
bonnes
l'internaute les chéris merci à pas mal
moyenne 25 54 ouais ça fait une moyenne
de 5,2 vous passez devant benjamin
castaldi oui c'était pas non plus
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
tu sais quoi c'est quoi ta répartissez
le
vbcc de lever complètement le
tableau de partout bien choisir plus
rien pigé bouard est
vrai qu'on ne sait pas quelle va être
tes lèvres bougent mais décembre surtout
paul
valéry est franchement c'est pas mal
ouais c'est pas mal et je voudrais dire
moi valérie je lui ai mis huit sur dix
ans aulas à valérie bénaïm
chiens qui font rage avant que j'avais
pas de donner votre note nos rêves et
ouais je vous avais mis
200 ex
non non je crois qu'il a émis 7 1 s'est
tous été mis à mal par m'agacer vous
êtes sûr ouais pourquoi les riches en
fer chez mimi vite car c'est celle qui
rit le plus c'est important le rire est
d'être d'arcade dans l'émission et
valérie apporte une énorme touche de dar
k et la dar k c'est le sens même de la
vie après c'est le sens même de
l'émission quelli avec de la dark ah
ouais faut lire y amène de la barca
guillaume amendola l'arc à raymond amène
de la barca
les autres
vous êtes
quand même de l'avoir canada monsieur
rigole vous avez tous à l'art comme
c'est vrai que valérie c'est quand même
si c'est important je dis souvent
d'avoir quelqu'un qui met l'ambiance
mais elle met l'ambiance s etc etc c'est
comme à la radio on dit souvent il a on
a besoin de quelqu'un qui avait beaucoup
à la radio pour rythmer démission et
valérie et kelis rx-7 qui rythment
l'émission tous les jours si valérie
kelly ne rit pas c'est que la vanne
voilà bah regarde